hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Super Mario maker to the
wonderful game with wonderful levels
that make me so happy
kaboom make I know I don't do the making
I just do the playing and I do the
screaming alright so story mode story
mode want a story but didn't even know a
story was possible okay uh well it
wasn't he oh god already bored course
world I think is what we want for
playing in course world let's create a
me and make a name for your maker avatar
alright start from scratch there that's
my strong jawline and my luscious beard
oh the shadows under my eye I like that
actually give some nice depth luscious
locks ah m4 mark or man dark but I'm
gonna go m4 markiplier which that
clearly is show more red we're gonna go
read m4 markup laughs are always crying
Vic eyes fierce piercing a stunning
captivating board yeah that's more like
me that's me alright
position up wide there we go yeah dreary
dreary a little drear a droll even there
we go turd brown no strong German nut
not that up not that down not the full
Squidward mouth luck Oh nope small tiny
mouth tiny mouth Oh Oh tiny mouth haul
Oh
tolik yes this is me this is the real
nut wait hang on oh no wait no no not
like this the market blew love it okay
here we go
of course is yeah all right what do we
got hot course spicy spicy course
popular courses okay all right here we
go
2.5
seven I like the time a real tight
alright here we go I'm so ready let me
add let me add okay okay okay okay
oh I messed up already oh [ __ ] oh no
I've forgotten that these things are
actually hard ah oh why can't the jump
be something else oh god I don't like
having to hold down a button and then
pushing oh boy oh boy my control is
broken everything is broken let me try
this
I just remembered maybe this might
actually be better okay alright that's
the frick hold on to your horses it's
gonna be a bumpy ride
alright here we go we're doing great
[Music]
right oh there we go alright nailed it
nailed nailed nailed it nailed nailed it
nailed it nailed it nailed it I've got
this on lock oh the best oh yeah I
remember I'm gonna really hate that
sound after a while I'm gonna start to
hate that sound oh okay Oh spicy spicy
oh how do I do I can't do that listen
probably oh yes oh wait no there
shouldn't be more lies anymore Oh No
okay it's fine this is easy this is
nothing Oh
no no no no no no no no no aah no okay
I mean it's it's gotta be it's up no
it's just a lot of it's just a lot of
really precise jumps that's all it is
that's all this is just a lot of real
precise O's a lot of real oh it's a lot
I hate this controller but there's
nothing I can do about it I miss the big
ol Wii U you know those that was good
times was good times
them's was real good times them's was
the best of times they were it may have
been the worst of times but you know you
know you know you know you know you know
you know you know zero seconds left
Oh God Oh No wait hang on no you can't
do that to me do that so just he's just
gonna sit down oh no he doesn't sit down
anymore oh I thought that's what
happened how did you get that fast
how you squeeze out point that many more
seconds something about frame perfection
I think okay pretty good pretty not bad
pretty 10% sneeze my my dong no oh
what's that I can't do it all right here
we go 20 seconds pow pow pow block blitz
all right okay go no thanks dude come on
okay well oh oh how do you what oh wait
that was possible okay oh I'm gonna get
you oh uh I thought if you touched it
with it it would go boom why did it go
boom when you touch them with maybe
because it's not a block of TNT that's
what I like oh yeah Oh oops
ah oh boy oh goodness gracious
watch this point Oh God and we got it
yeah nailed it did one for Flair there
yeah oh no that's gay Oh got you
oh my god I'm the best they never get
some Oh nut okay dude that and then put
oh not up
I meant rooted over oh yeah here we go
wait wait for it I'm ran out of time now
so now I'm oh [ __ ] oh I probably can't
lose momentum you can't do the momentum
losin you can't lose momentum
maybe you lose momentum then you're
gonna go far better not lose it oh you
can't I know what you have to do I know
I feel it I know you have to know oh boy
no I can't boy I got a dying perfect
just like that baby
just like that here we go he's beautiful
he's breathe oh yeah oh yeah ah that's
how I do I love it I love it a little
bit whomp terror an angry flop is
chasing you keep running and try to be
faster alright fine I'll do that yeah no
problem
yeah no problem oh no problem yeah no
problem dude
I was at the thwomp okay oh oh oh that's
problem oh wait wait wait hang on I like
all the new effects that they're gonna
have in this oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot
why do you have ghosts on your head you
weirdo boy incus and whoa-oh-oh i don't
know how that hook works oh I was just
about to say it's not so bad because
it's not oh yeah oh yeah now we're in
the swing of things ha get it yeah
all right here we go oh boy what am i
doing I don't know I'm citing reading
this oh that worked out for me oh okay
we're fine
everything's good oh there's more oh
there's more oh they made a save at
least which is awfully nice of them Oh
got it oh not bad they scared me I
didn't know what was gonna happen so why
would I think that I would just be able
to keep going I've never encountered
this I also don't know what like all the
new mechanics in this crap are so I know
how is good go from me oh god I don't
know how he's gonna go for me oh no oh
I did it I did great I did great guys I
did great it's literally impossible
don't lie to me 20 seconds buzzy beetle
blaze all right let's do it
bruh here we go oh yeah that's what I'm
talking about oh that's fine
ooh you need to hit that right it's fine
I don't know what I'm doing
mechanics are weird all right let's make
it happen captain let's do it right yeah
okay yeah all right I got you hey listen
things are gonna be good
all right cool great I love this oh yeah
that's what I'm talking about and have
been talking about my entire existence
yeah now now we are talking hey must
save some for me
ha ha no don't be a nerd down all right
let's get back into the swing of things
back on the horse you jump back on I
jump off you jump off I back on pop it
right back up on the horse you know how
I am always when I quit I go fail I
ignore when I feel like a win I don't
I'm no quitter
I'm no quitter because I know how to do
it with victory in my blood I'm gonna
I'm gonna feel I feel the heat I feel
the passion I feel I feel the power i
feel compelled I feel strong I feel
strong I feel strong
[Music]
all right let's get back on that horse
let's do this again I am ready you are
ready we are all ready and we are gonna
get it today this is a good day full of
sunshine butterflies I feel good as I
should do let's get that nailed that
nailed that Oh what did you say to me
nothing
[Music]
spectacular switch sprint I'm willing to
bet that there's gonna be a lot of
Sprint's going on which is weird cuz I
don't remember there being that many
Sprint's and the other one I mean yeah I
was all trying to be fast but there seem
to be what's gonna happen which is
really cool it's like oh what's gonna
happen which is really cool is that
there's gonna be an evolution as people
get better at making levels because that
was like the beautiful thing about the
original okay I just gotta have faith
and believe as people get better at it
the levels are going to be like get
really fun really weird okay I think I I
was trying to go for the jumpy block and
I don't know why so I'm dumb is the
answer to that question is I'm real bum
guys real thumb real this guys don't
worry about you me I worry about what
excuse ah this one didn't even have it
as bad a completion percentage but it
just feels like I need to panic which
I've known I'm sure I don't I'm sure I
don't I'm sure
[Music]
here we go this is gonna be the one this
is it is the one I feel it I feel it's
good it's a good thing you know back in
the saddle I feel the saddle I feel it I
feel the saddle you know
riding a little high feel that saddle
right between my butt cheeks I feel it
up smash that like button if you feel
the saddle in yes oh wait no hang on you
gotta let me in there no you okay all
right
so that is gonna be enough for this
first episode there's a lot of good
stuff out here I'm sure I'm not even
unlike super expert this is just expert
so I'm sure there's much worse but I
think it's a good base level a good base
level oh so guys if you know anything in
the story mode that I need to know about
let me know down in the comments below I
don't think I need to play it and I
think it's just to like get people into
it and give them something to do that's
not like user-generated levels but you
know if there's something in there that
needs to be done let me know if you want
to see more of this let me know down
there thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other Super Mario
maker series I did on the original game
in the description below playlists
recommended videos over there and thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]